if you want to bring in big customers
and and sponsors they're going to expect
a lot for for what they what they spend
and you better have the amenities that
they're used to what's what's Michael
say about that Michael Jordan for those
who don't know yeah I mean he's just
been a great partner uh how did you talk
him into this I know he's in the race he
used to be into bikes right he did he he
owned a motorcycle team and so just
local back it all started during covet
and obviously I'm like well what am I
going to do and immediately I asked
David Wilson like is there any interest
in me owning a race team you know jjr
was losing uh LFR coveted took its toll
on a race team that was a Toyota team
I'm like can I pick up the pieces of
that team and kind of bring it in and
start a new team and and wow were you
drunk when you thought of this idea I
that's what Joe asked me he's like are
you crazy uh you're making all the money
now why do you want to go spend it but
um I just thought that you know I wanted
to have my say and honestly I got down
to Richard Petty Motorsports and that
was a team that I was looking to buy a
minority stake in but ultimately I found
that I wasn't going to get the control
that I needed the autonomy to really run
it the way that I thought it needed to
be run and so I'm like yeah this isn't
the right fit for me either and Bubba
Wallace was a free agent and he had some
sponsorship with him and I'm like you
know what how can I put all this
together because Bubba used to be part
of the Toyota Racing family and even
with Joe Gibbs Racing how can I put all
these pieces of the puzzle back together
and so
actually a speculative article came out
and it said
that Denny Hamlin and Michael Jordan
were looking to purchase a minority
stake in Richard Petty Mercer's which
was absolutely not true I never even
talked to Jordan about this at all and
so
um a lot of it started from the rumors
from the ownership at RPM at the time
they had other celebrity people that
were looking to buy a minority stake in
there and people just assumed that that
celebrity was Michael Jordan because I
was friends with him absolutely not true
I took this article the headline and I
sent it to Michael and I'm like let's
just see what he says here so I sent it
to him and he says well that's obviously
not true it's fake news but if you want
to make it real news let me know I'm
like
okay
how do I respond to this now never
forget I was on the ninth hole at the
golf course on my second shot and I got
so fluttered that I left my ball sitting
there I went to the green and they're
like dude you didn't even hit your shot
and I'm like oh I gotta go back and get
my ball because I'm like how do I
respond to this and so he says well are
you gonna be a team owner or not and I
says
I'm thinking about it why he says well
if you are and you want a partner let me
know and I says
when can you meet he's like so I says
all right I'll be there in two days I
got my team at Pro support management to
essentially type up a business plan
here's here's here's how it's going to
go
they worked day and night to get me this
this business plan to give to him and I
gave it to him and I says you know
here's the plan he's like all right well
it looks good to me but it's got to get
vetted so he gave it to his business
people they spent about a month getting
NASCAR 101 education on all this first
they asked like are you kidding me this
business model is terrible I'm like I
know but it could get better it's
possible that it could get better these
are the best or the worst time in the
whole wide world that's right we will
know we will know and you guys like to
gamble that's correct and so uh you know
listen for us we you know that we've
decided to pull the trigger a month
later he says I'm in and we started a
race team which has now been 18 months
ago so it's it's crazy how it all
started we we've won you know three
races in in the lat in the year and
three quarters that we've been in the
sport which is unbelievable are you
surprised by that
because it's so hard
let alone when you just start a team
this is not easy beating Motorsports and
Joe Gibbs Racing that have been around
for decades is hard and yeah
in Ford versus Ferrari when they make it
look like it's people were like oh my
gosh Is that real I'm like it's harder
than what they made it look like there's
more politics than what they make it
look like I was like they just built a
car to go win at Le Mans like that does
not happen I know especially how
impressive what you've done yeah it's
just been crazy because you know it is
hard to come in here and win and so for
us to have three wins already it's just
been amazing
um we're on a trajectory I told everyone
this this is a five-year plan I told
Michael Curtis my whole team this is a
five-year plan to be a championship
contending organization
um that is a real timeline now we are
only in year
1.8 or so right so this is still a
building process but you know we have
some big plans on the horizon that we're
working on we're kind of waiting to see
where this model goes before we pull the
trigger on them but ultimately I feel
like we are going to be a team that wins
races on a regular basis every single
year uh you know at least a year or two
from now like I you know we're already
competitive we're already listen in the
final you know we already punched our
ticket in the owners Championship to the
next round uh with Bubba Wallace so it's
just uh really been amazing the run that
we've been on and bringing on Kurt Busch
was just one of the best things we ever
did I love her I think Kurt's a great
guy and he's very helpful he's a very
helpful teammate as well so I'm sure
he's been helping in that category well
I actually I'm wondering what is going
on with him
um but first first before I ask that
question
um are you more surprised to be winning
races we'll have won a race in your
first year and have three wins at this
point in time with that with not even
being completed with the second season
or are you more surprised that it's
Bubba do you more surprised the bubble
one
a couple times oh that is a great
question
I would say
that I'm more surprised with Baba and I
thought he was very good but I didn't
realize the potential that he has now I
it was a bumpy first 10 months trust me
with Bobby it was like you know
trying to get him to okay here but
here's my process in which I get ready
for races here's the data that I look at
here's what I think you need to be
studying
and it's tough because
I expect him to have the same work ethic
as me but like I can't control him right
I can't all I can do is say here's
here's the formula that works for me
hopefully it can work for you but I
realized quickly that like he needs to
be his own person he needs to do the
things that he he sees correctly and I'm
really really proud of like how he has
progressed as a NASCAR driver like the
strides he has taken just in the last 10
months has been unbelievable he's taken
himself he's done to do that I admit
he's taking himself from a mid-pack guy
to someone that runs
chronically in the top 10 every single
week now and so like it's just been
great to watch because he's now seeing
the results of the work that he's
putting in and so it's always tough
because if you don't see results from
work that you put in it's easy to quit
right away right it's like I'm not here
for the long game I'm here for the the
immediate gratification and I think that
you know we trying to walk them him
through this process that here's what
it's going to take for you to be better
down the road and here's what you need
to be keeping notes on for next time and
I think he's started to do that and
started to see great results and now I
think it works like me now he's feeding
off of it and and give me more give me
more because he's starting to see
results and see his true potential wow
well good job in teaching him but it
sounds like he just started to work
harder yeah I think he he really started
to buy into the the things that we asked
him to do uh the things that we asked
him to study and you know ultimately you
have to want it right I mean this is a
that everyone is is so good and I've
realized in my older age that I have to
I don't have the natural talent that
most of these good drivers have I can I
just work hard that's just a fact I feel
like I work hard and I work on my craft
really hard and you know I'm open to new
things if I need to drive things
differently fine then then whatever I
need to do to to get better as a driver
I never have stopped learning as a
driver even 18 years in and so
um I think that that's what we're trying
to instill into our drivers is for them
to be the best that they can be and
we're starting to see it
okay let me give you a scenario
so you race for
three more years
you get
eight more wins
but you don't win a championship or this
year you win a championship
and you're done you're done after this
Championship when you win in after you
win it or in three years you'll never
won a championship
and you'll have retired and you'll but
you'll have like eight more wins which
is a couple more each year which you're
pretty good for
yeah I mean for me I know I want to get
to 60. I want to get to 60 where are you
at 48.
um you're not there so you won't make
60.
yeah you'll get eight more you'll Race
for three more years but you won't have
a championship
this is tough but I'm gonna take more
wins I'm gonna take getting to 60 with
no Championship you can't get to 60
though you get eight more that's it
but if you're saying I win a
championship this year and I'm at 48
wins and I'm done I would rather have 60
wins and no Championship three years
from now just simply because I value the
wins more so uh and I value the
Championships less than what I do have
in in years past because the way they
crown the champion is just a lot
different than it used to be it's just
one race now and it's like
I won 60 of those so what's the big deal
right we've had Champions that have won
like 10 races so yeah 60 is means like
you've had a long career and it's been
successful throughout your career to me
that means more
um do I want a championship absolutely I
mean am I tired of hearing about it yes
but it doesn't Define me I mean people
know all my competitors know when I hit
the racetrack they're gonna have to beat
me to go win the race this weekend and
so that's all I care about is is having
the respect for my peers that I am one
of the best regardless of whatever I
have in that stat column of a
championship
foreign